>> Jill Garcia: Good morning.
Welcome to the National
Book Festival.
How are you guys this morning?
[ Applause ]
All right!
All day here at the
Library Congress,
Library of Congress
National Book Festival,
we are recognizing and
celebrating the importance
of reading and authors
and books.
The Library of Congress makes it
seem easy to do this every year.
But the truth is, the
National Book Festival is a
huge undertaking.
And it is free for everyone
because of generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
at loc.gov/donate
from the festival app
and when you purchase
books today.
And now onto the main event.
But let me first introduce
who you're all waiting to see.
Brendan Wenzel is an author
and illustrator from New York
who has a great affection
for all things furry,
scaly and feathered.
He's traveled the
jungles and savannas
and other really cool places in
search of fascinating animals,
and has teamed up
with different groups,
working to preserve wild
places and creatures
from around the world.
His debut picture book,
They All Saw a Cat,
was a New York Times bestseller,
and was the recipient
of the 2017 Caldecott Honor.
But today we're going to talk
about his new book, Hello Hello,
which introduces us to
92 different animals,
many of which are
endangered and threatened.
Just so you know,
after his presentation,
he's going to be signing in
line 20 from 10:30 to 11:30.
Please welcome Brendan Wenzel.
[ Applause ]
>> Brendan Wenzel: Thank you.
Thank you for coming
out so early.
I'm just going to throw
on my [inaudible].
How's everybody doing?
[ Applause ]
All right, let's see,
can everybody hear me?
All right, hello?
Oh, I know it's early, but
we can do better than that.
Let's try this.
Hello hello.
>> Hello hello.
>> Brendan Wenzel: Hola!
>> Hola!
>> Brendan Wenzel: Allo.
>> Allo.
>> Brendan Wenzel: Xin chao.
>> Xin chao.
>> Brendan Wenzel: All right,
anyone want to give
this one a try?
[ Background noises ]
That's actually how
elephants say hello.
All right, so who
am I, and why am I
up here saying hello
to everybody?
Well, I'm saying hello
because hello is one
of my favorite words.
No matter what language
you're speaking, hello is kind
of where we begin, right?
It's the very first
thing we say to someone.
It's our way of connecting
with another person,
right, or another animal.
And so who am I?
My name is Brendan Wenzel, and I
am an illustrator and an author.
And illustrator means that
I draw pictures for books,
and an author means
that I write the words.
So these are some of the
books that I've created
over the past few years up here.
[ Applause ]
My most-- well, thank you.
Wow. My most recent book,
however, is called Hello Hello,
and it's all about animals
from across the world,
some of my favorites,
and how they relate
to one another, how
they connect.
But I'm going to tell you a
little bit about this book.
But before I do, I would
love to tell you a little bit
about myself and my work
and some of the experiences
that have shaped my artwork.
So I've always had these
two things that I've loved.
I call them the two As.
These are animals, and
the other one is art.
These have been the
things I've loved
since I was a really,
really little kid.
Just to prove it to you,
here's a photo of me when I was
about 10 years old, and I'm
kind of wearing this kind
of Indiana Jonesish outfit
that I cobbled together
from my parents' wardrobe.
And I'm at my favorite place in
the entire world at that time,
the Bronx Zoo in New York City.
It's actually still one
of my favorite places.
And I'm staring off
at a lion here.
And but maybe what's more
important is what's surrounding
me, what's surrounding
this photo,
because these are all the books
that shaped how I saw the world
when I was a kid, and they
shaped how I saw animals,
my favorite subject.
These books taught me that
animals were fascinating
and beautiful creatures.
These books taught me
that animals were
extraordinary creatures.
These books taught me that
animals were funny and kind
of charming creatures.
These books taught me that
animals were individuals, right,
animals had their own
character, and each was unique.
And what these books
showed me as a whole is
that animals had really, really
interesting stories to tell us,
really important stories,
and that we needed to listen.
So when I first started making
my own stories, they were also--
whoa, got ahead of myself.
There was another kind of book
that I loved when I was a kid,
and these were not storybooks,
but they told a kind of story.
These books are called
field guides.
Has anyone heard
this term before?
Who's heard the term
field guide?
Okay, great, a few of you.
So field guides are one of
my favorite type of books.
Field guides tell the
story of one area.
They tell the story of all the
animals that live in that area.
And when I look at the page of
a field guide, it enabled me
to see all the creatures
that lived around my house
in Connecticut, and the
ways that they were similar,
but also all the incredible
ways that they were different,
all the things that they-- all
the shapes and sizes and forms
that the animal kingdom
has taken.
And when I was a kid,
what I would love
to do is spread all my field
guides out on the floor.
And when I would look at all of
these field guides side by side
and I would see all
these animals,
I would get this feeling of
wonder, because I would think
about how vast and exciting
the natural world is.
So when I first started
to make books,
those books were about animals.
My very first book
was about animals.
It was called The Frog.
And I worked on this when
I was in first grade.
The second book that I made
was also about animals.
This book was called
Land of the Little.
And Land of the Little
was about baby animals.
And I didn't know a lot about
baby animals at the time.
And so I did what you do
when you start a book.
I did research.
And to do my research, I wrote
a letter to my favorite place
in the entire world, the
Bronx Zoo, and I said,
"Dear Bronx Zoo, my
name is Brendan Wenzel.
I go to John Lyman School,
I am eight years old.
I am studying baby animals."
I thought the Bronx Zoo could
give me some helpful information
for my project.
And the Bronx Zoo
actually wrote me back,
which was really exciting for
me, and they gave me two really,
really helpful pieces of advice.
They said, if you're
starting a project,
there's two great places to go.
One, your school library,
the library at your school.
And number two, your
local library.
And this is still advice
that I follow today.
And this is what I tell young
authors when they want to start.
I say, "there's no
better place to start
than your local library."
So I kept drawing
animals, and I drew animals
when I was in middle school.
I drew animals when I went
to art school, which is one
of the places you
can go in you want
to become a professional
illustrator.
I drew space animals
in art school,
but they were still animals.
And now as an adult, I'm really
lucky, and I get to travel all
over the place meeting animals,
like this kea, which is a parrot
from New Zealand, and these
wild geese in Australia,
and this little orange
squiggle on my arm.
Does anyone have any idea
what that squiggle is?
Who knows what that squiggle is?
What is that squiggle?
>> A snake?
>> Brendan Wenzel:
It is a snake.
That is a, that is a little
snake called a whipsnake.
And I am making this
face in the photograph
because my good friend, Puma,
has just snuck up behind me.
Puma is a guide in the jungle.
And he put that snake on my arm
and then told me, "don't worry,
it's only a little bit
venomous, just a little bit."
So I'm not too happy
with Puma in this photo.
But I don't just love
looking at animals.
I'm an illustrator.
So what I love to
do is draw animals.
And everywhere I go,
I bring my sketchbook,
I bring my sketchbook with me.
Now, does anybody here
keep a sketchbook?
Does anyone have a sketchbook?
Okay, a few of you.
But I'm going to, I'm going to
make a bold suggestion today
that everyone here should
try keeping a sketchbook.
And I know, I'm pretty sure what
I'll hear is everyone saying,
"oh, I don't like to draw, I
don't like the drawings I do."
And my, my thought is
that it doesn't matter
if you do the best
drawing you've ever done
in a sketchbook.
So to give you an example,
this is a drawing that I did
when I was in South Africa,
the country of South Africa.
And if we look at this,
this is a herd of elephants.
I had woken up early in
the morning and I drove
out into the savanna,
and this big herd
of elephants crossed
in front of my car.
And you look at this elephant
over here on the left-hand side.
And that looks just as much
kind of like a sack of potatoes
as it does an elephant, right?
That's not the best drawing
of a glorious African
elephant you've ever seen.
But the point of
this drawing was not
to do the best drawing
of elephants.
What I wanted to do was
capture this moment.
And when I look back at
this, at this sketch,
I can remember everything
about that moment.
I remember how the
savanna smelled,
the birds chirping
in the background.
And so a sketchbook can
be this really cool way
of bringing your ideas and
your memories back with you.
It's the same with this cheetah
and this lion and these gibbons
that I drew in a
country called Thailand.
So another cool thing is
if you are an illustrator,
sometimes one little sketch
you do in your sketchbook goes
on to become a finished
illustration.
So this is an animal called
a white-handed gibbon.
And sometimes you do one
illustration like this
and you get so excited
that you do a lot more.
So this is a series of drawings
that I did of animals that live
in a place called Vietnam
or in southeast Asia,
way over on the other side of
the world where I actually used
to live for two years.
And when I did these drawings,
I did them because I wanted
to learn more about these
animals, because I was
so excited about them, and I
wanted to share that excitement
with people around me.
Some of the people I
shared this drawing
with had this really cool job.
And that job is called
wildlife conservationist.
Has anyone heard
this term before?
It's a big term.
Okay, some of you.
So for anybody out there
who doesn't know what this
means, let me tell you.
Okay, so wildlife is just
another word for animals, right?
Wild animals, animals that
live out in the forest, yeah.
And a conservationist
is someone who wants
to conserve something
or protect it, right?
So wildlife conservationists,
in my mind,
are kind of like superheroes.
They're like superheroes
for animals.
At least that's how I feel.
And I think the animals
would probably feel that way
if they understood
what was happening.
So when I showed my drawing
to wildlife conservationists,
they said, "hey, you seem
like you're really excited
about these animals.
We are also really
excited about them.
And a big part of our job is
to get other people
excited about animals."
So they said, "why
don't we team up and try
to make some work together to
get other people enthusiastic
about all these cool
creatures that we love?"
And so I've been really
lucky, and I've gotten to work
with real-life wildlife
conservationists
on all kinds of projects.
On stickers, in books,
on T-shirts, on posters.
But one of my favorite
things I've done is this map
of a country called Cambodia.
Now, the country of
Cambodia is right next
to where I used to
live in Vietnam.
And the folks that I made
this map with, and I wanted
to show people all these
beautiful green parks
that you can find throughout
the country of Cambodia,
because what we wanted
is for people
to be excited about
these places.
Because when you're
excited about something,
you want to protect it, right?
Another cool thing about this
map was that I worked on it
with a group called The
Wildlife Conservation Society.
Now, The Wildlife Conservation
Society has another project
that they work on.
And that is the Bronx
Zoo in New York City.
So a few years ago, I
actually got to team
up with the Bronx Zoo and
help redesign their brand new
children's zoo.
So this is the sketch that
they originally sent me
of what they wanted to create.
And then in 2015, I got to walk
through the front entranceway--
this is the zoo on opening day--
of the Bronx Zoo surrounded by
my images, and to know that my,
my loves and my interest in art
and animals had come together
and helped me contribute to
this place that I've loved
since I was a little kid.
It was just one of the
coolest experiences of my life.
Another great thing about this
project was that the designers,
Jen, Sara and Kimeo
[phonetic], wanted the viewer,
wanted the person
coming to the zoo to feel
like they were walking
into a picture book.
They wanted you to feel like
you were in a storybook.
Because they wanted you to
connect with these animals
in a way that you wouldn't if
you were just watching them walk
through their enclosure,
which in itself is a
pretty cool experience.
But this was a great question
for me to think about,
because I think for someone
like myself who loves animals
and who loves art, this
question is at the heart
of what I want to
do with my work.
How can I take my feelings
about animals, my excitement
and my enthusiasm, and
share it with all of you?
How can I get you
excited about animals?
And this is why I feel
so lucky that I get
to make picture books.
My first book, They
All Saw a Cat,
was all about how animals see.
It's all about how animals
see this one thing, this cat,
this little brown cat with a red
collar, and how all these things
like location and
emotion and physiology,
how our actual bodies
work, how our eyes work,
can all change how we see
the same subject matter.
So a few, like a few years
ago, I started walking
around my studio, and I knew I
wanted to write another book,
and I knew I wanted to share
my excitement for animals.
And so I thought about, I
thought about being a kid,
and I thought, what got
me really interested
in animals when I was a kid?
And I thought about spreading
all my field guides out.
And that feeling of
wonder I would get
when I would look
at field guides.
And so I started drawing
in my sketchbook, right,
because that's what I do.
But I didn't want to draw
all animals from one area.
I wanted to draw all
my favorite animals.
So I started with a zebra,
a black and white zebra.
And then I drew a
black and white eel.
And then I draw a
black and white fish.
And then I said, "okay, I don't
want to draw any more animals
with black and white stripes."
So I drew a fish
with the same shape.
So I had a black and white
fish and a yellow fish,
but they had that same shape.
And I started thinking
about all the other ways
that animals could
connect, and the sequence
of animals got longer
and longer,
and then it got really long,
and then it just spread out all
over the page and branched out.
And I eventually wrote
at the top of the page,
animal relationship
super sequence.
This was every animal
that I could think of
and how they related
to one another.
But I thought, if I
make this into a book,
I'm going to be working
on this book
for the next thousand years.
And it would probably take
a hundred years to read it.
So I narrowed my
sequence down to this,
and I had this super
line of animals.
But they were all
these different animals
that they all related.
So let's try this.
So here we have this, this
little line from my sketchbook.
We've got a leopard
and we've got a fish.
What do they have in common?
>> Spots!
>> Brendan Wenzel:
Exactly, spots.
We've got this frog
and this duck.
What do they have in common?
They both have?
>> Webbed feet!
>> Brendan Wenzel:
Webbed feet, exactly.
And then we've got that
duck and a platypus.
What do a duck and a
platypus have in common?
>> A bill!
>> Brendan Wenzel:
A bill, exactly.
So I was really excited
by this idea.
But the one thing I
didn't have is something
to tie this whole book together.
What was one thing that was
happening on every page?
And then I thought about my
favorite word, hello, right?
Because hello is what
we say when we want
to connect with someone.
It's that first moment
of connection.
And this became the
book Hello Hello.
And so Hello Hello is
all about connections.
It's all about how animals
relate to one another
and how they relate to us.
I'm not going to read Hello
Hello with you here today
because I want to tell you
about a secret mission I had
with this book that not a
lot of people know about.
But I'm going to
tell you about it.
So if you flip through
Hello Hello, you'll start
by seeing a lot of animals
you recognize, right?
We've got a black bear,
a panda bear, a zebra.
Most people know these animals.
But if you keep moving
throughout the book,
you start to see animals that
might not be quite as familiar.
You've got a tiger and a cheetah
are probably pretty familiar.
But then we've got
a whale shark.
And then on this page, we've
got a monkey called a proboscis
monkey, and an animal
called a Senegal galago
with these big ears.
We've got an aardvark.
And what I wanted to do
with Hello Hello is introduce
my readers to some animals
that I think are really cool,
but that I don't think
get enough attention.
I wanted to shine a
spotlight on them.
I'm not through writing the
whole book, but I did want
to show you the last page.
This is the closest
thing I could get
to my animal relationship
super sequence.
It's one of the final
pages in this book.
And what I hope the reader
feels when they look at it is
that same sense of wonder that
I would feel when I would look
at field guides as a kid.
I wanted them to think
about all the different ways
that animals connect, and how
beautiful and biodiverse life
on our planet is, how many
different shapes and sizes
and colors it's taken.
There were a few more pages that
I thought were really important
to include in this book.
And that was a way
that people can figure
out what these animals are.
Because ultimately, ultimately,
my goal for this book is for you
to close it and want to learn
more about all the animals
that I wrote about here.
And so what I wanted to do
is let you have a tool to go
to the library, pick up
a book and learn more.
Because these are all
really, really cool animals.
And just to prove that,
I'm going to tell you a
little bit more about one
of my absolute favorites.
This is the animal
from the cover,
and it's called a
Sunda pangolin.
It's kind of peeking
out at you here.
So a Sunda pangolin is
covered in these hard scales,
but they're actually
not a reptile.
They're a mammal
just like you and I.
Sunda pangolins are about
the size of a house cat,
and they live all the way on
the other side of the world
in southeast Asia
where I used to live.
So Sunda pangolins are
fascinating animals
for tons of reasons.
They have this cool
prehensile tail,
which they can use
to climb up in trees.
It's kind of like
some species of monkey
that can actually grab branches.
Sunda pangolins, they have these
two big strong powerful claws,
and they dig down in the dirt
looking for their favorite food.
Who has a guess as what a
pangolin's favorite food is?
What do you think?
>> Bugs?
>> Brendan Wenzel: Bugs.
It is bugs.
It's a very specific
kind of bug.
What do we think right here?
>> Ants.
>> Brendan Wenzel: Exactly!
They love ants.
They love ants and termites.
And when Sunda pangolins
find ants and termites,
they use this long sticky tongue
to just slurp them right up just
like you slurp up
cake and pizza.
There is some bad news, though.
I have a little bit of bad news.
Sunda pangolins are actually
hunted for their scales.
And this means that they are one
of the most endangered animals
on planet Earth right now,
which is really, really sad.
They're critically endangered,
which is the most
endangered an animal can be.
But there's also good news.
And that good news
is these two folks.
This is T and M, my
friends from Thailand,
they're real-life
wildlife conservationists,
and they're doing
important work,
protecting pangolin habitat,
doing field monitoring,
trying to figure out how
many pangolins are actually
in the wild.
And maybe some of the most
important work they're doing is
educating people, sharing
their excitement for pangolin.
So I was actually
able to go this year
and help them teach people
about pangolin through my art
in Thailand, which was a
really fun experience for me.
So why do we, why do we want
to protect pangolin, right,
this one species of animal on
the other side of the world,
this one little animal?
I mean, they're fascinating
and they're beautiful,
and I think that
should be enough.
But in case you're not sold
on that, think about this.
When you protect one pangolin,
if you protect just one
individual pangolin,
you have to protect
its home, right?
You've got to protect
the place that it lives.
And if you protect the place
that it lives, its habitat,
you don't only protect
that pangolin,
but you protect all the animals
that share that ecosystem.
So this is why protecting
species is so important.
Wildlife conservationists
actually have a name
for these really familiar
animals that they use
to represent one place.
And these are called
ambassador species,
animals that represent a whole
bunch of different species.
An ambassador is someone who
goes to represent a bunch
of individuals, right?
So, in Hello Hello, I
included over 90 animals.
There are over 90
animals in this book.
And my secret hope was that
maybe I could introduce people
to some new potential
ambassador species,
animals that might help
protect entire places.
And that 90 animals, when
I was working on this book,
felt like a whole lot.
This book took me
two years to make.
But in the scheme of things,
those animals are just
a drop in the bucket.
We share our planet with 5,416
species of mammal, 6,514 species
of amphibian, 8,734 species of
reptile, 9,990 species of bird,
31,153 species of fish.
And that's only including
the vertebrae,
the animal with backbones
that are most similar to us.
If I include the invertebrates,
that's over a million
more animals.
So if you think about that,
if you're only focusing
on those animals that
are most similar to us,
that's 60,000 stories that
are waiting to be told, right,
waiting to be shared,
waiting to be learned.
And this is where-- I've only
got a couple minutes left here--
but I want to ask each and
every one of you for help.
Because on average, I make
about one book every year.
That's as many books
as I can make.
Sometimes two if I'm lucky.
So what I'm asking all of
you is to give me a hand.
So however you tell
stories, whether it's
through drawing pictures
or writing or making songs
or theater or dance,
please tell the world
about your favorite animals.
Tell them why you
think they're exciting,
why you think they make
things more fascinating,
more charming, more beautiful.
And the great news is if
you want to learn more
about animals, it's
not that tough.
You don't have to go all the way
to the other side of the world.
You can just follow the advice
the Wildlife Conservation
Society and the Bronx Zoo
gave me many, many years ago.
Go down to your local library,
pick up a book on crocodiles,
on aardvarks, on nematodes,
and just say hello.
I'm Brendan Wenzel.
That's my time.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]